do you think aliens see that at the dark
side of the earth like they see our
lights projected outside I don't think
they can they don't have the eyes huh
they're asexual okay
[Music]
do you guys see the new Artemis launch
from nasus yeah so nasty Artemis is that
a uh satellite it's a big old rocket
wonderful oh yep so uh 50 years after
the first uh the final Apollo mission
NASA has taken the first steps that that
were we need to take to return to the
moon so Artemis was launched this was
funded a couple years back right and
they they actually launched it this um
well whenever you see this but for us it
was like yesterday
um and
they're basically trying to get this
rocket up into space
in order to prep
um the moon mission which will be within
a couple of years are they gonna do
anything different this time when they
get to the moon well they're gonna
a video of them so it doesn't feel fake
anymore which will be wild they don't
get high def video it still comes back
in 420p
just the transfer files it's just too
big something about the moon because it
went from iPhone to Android yeah
that's the moon one of the weird Parts
about this for conspiracy theorists
which by the way I don't hate that term
like a lot of things that are
conspiracies turned to be true later but
um for this one it's kind of interesting
because this is a 26 day flight right so
this thing's gonna orbit
um the Earth carrying a set of
mannequins with sensors to study
conditions during the flight to measure
radiation levels throughout the mission
so it's like
well if we already went to the moon you
know yeah yeah what's the deal for that
and I look legit I'm the biggest space
fan Moon fan ever
but this is uh smoking wait do you feel
like the the moon landing was real or
fake I think it was 100 fake but I love
it and I'm gonna you love Buzz Moon
conspiracies are really fun they're fun
the video is cool Hollow Moon [__] and
like the moon wait what's Halloween
now we're gonna so when we landed on the
moon apparently the instrumentation that
we had like on the surface
um said the moon rang like a bell like
it's it's a hollow moon it's like
there's some kind of internal core to it
who the [__] Knows by the way was the
instrumentation malfunctioning oh wait
when we returned to the Moon with a
heavier payload so when we like drop the
Lander on the moon with even heavier
this time it rang like a bell for seven
hours whoa wild so again we don't know
what the [__] [__] we don't know what's
drilled down into the moon we don't know
we don't absolutely know yeah but it is
fascinating and fun and we have forget
to see the Dark Side of the Moon you
know what I mean you can't see it
because title locked it's always gonna
be titled locked you can't see the dark
side unless you fly around it only a
couple guys have Edgar Mitchell's the
first and they said there's a space
station a alien space station there they
say also that perhaps the entire moon is
a space station and that the back AKA
dark side of the man is just like the
thrusters but like if they came here
with thrusters they're not really that
advanced in my opinion but
so that Google moon thing
where we can see the moon it's actually
[__] it's it's the mother [__]
oh it's a big lot of [__] because we
only see one side always yeah and this
is a terrible movie but it doesn't
rotate it just one side it can't rotate
yeah because if they did that you'd see
the back of the spaceship brother oh
okay I forgot that I'm actually like the
biggest moon fan ever I [__] love the
mid missions but um they're they're
actually just trying to test to see like
where we're at right now with current
space technology how that the radiation
from the Van Allen belt will affect the
human body obviously it's like
experiments stop and then they're done
but that's what happens with conspiracy
people they're like why are they still
testing this [__] there because you have
to don't you exactly like [__] cars
to update the tech yeah you have to test
that [__] it's pressed everything all
right it's the best what is like a
private company like SpaceX fall into
stuff like this though you know what I
mean like who have been sending people
out there you know or not to the Moon
specifically but just like up into space
and kind of like you know come back yeah
how do you mean well like
um I guess if you're you know NASA and
you're testing for radiation for
astronauts to go up into space
Etc but then like you got a private
company right next to you and working
with you that sends people up into space
and stuff all right but they're not like
shared technology and the stuff like
that okay like that I don't know about
Share technology wise but the the Van
Allen belt is like where you would
experience the most radiation and it's
further away from the earth right so the
idea is like like you could a human
maybe couldn't survive as easily without
good protection right if you're not out
there with a [__] with Beach shorts
on it so that'll be cool they'll be sick
but you can't so like that's the idea is
like how how do you accomplish this
getting a human to the moon the safest
way obviously we did it because like you
know I'm firmed out of old age as far as
we know and Buzz is still kicking it and
Edgar Mitchell I think died recently a
couple years ago
but yeah they didn't die of like going
to the Moon yeah right space disease or
nothing yeah um which is what they were
tested for when they came back uh so
they're trying to see
um you know the most updated way that we
can go to the moon and this is part of
the first stage of that so if it's if
it's if it succeeds Artemis one will be
followed by a plan Artemis 2 test flight
which is scheduled for 2024 and that
mission will launch actual humans no
longer dummies and the Orion spacecraft
Craft on an expedition around the moon
and after that they will include the
first woman first person of color to
land on the moon boom on the Artemis
three what color cool yeah what color do
they pick yeah
look yeah look yeah who does that yeah
who does that you think it's yellow you
think it's me Brown what do you think I
hope he's white I hope it's the first
culture fit
I barely meet Colts fans who aren't
white so that's all that's the only
reason
we are a small white Market that's a
funny prank people of color we got our
person of color up there it's Colts
jersey Colts blue he bleeds blue
the first one we said there's a trans
hey
what's wrong with that
they're not a Colts fan
are you saying that he's a so he's a a
Colts and Steelers fan I think we only
need this camera
we can cut this one I believe the
footage it's just two dummies it's
static like this
if you had the chance to go to the Moon
would you do it yeah 100 100 wait what
if you can't go back but on Jeff bezos's
uh company bro how about this I went to
the Moon with Luna and I didn't come
back
rumor has it Steve is still up there so
rumor has it it's Hollow yeah it could
have been sweated
um but that was the lesson right it's
like when you go to the Moon all you
want to do is talk about how you went to
the moon yeah so like you go to the moon
and he's like let's get the [__] out of
here AKA you sell yeah and then you come
home
what do you really think is at the Dark
Side of the Moon what do I actually
think yeah trying to be really honest
with you yeah
nothing just empty not even moon it's a
backdriver it's empty because it's like
it's a dark side what do you hope is
there
oh man I would love if there were like
lights like how the Earth is dark at
night and you see lights or [__] love
that oh yeah that's cool you think
aliens see that at the dark side of the
earth like they see our lights projected
outside I don't think they can they
don't have the eyes huh they're asexual
okay they would never be sexual vaccines
dude [__] weirdos what's gonna happen
is if gray aliens do show up and they're
asexual we're just gonna be like man
look at these bait ass [__] yeah well
if they are asexual how come they keep
on anal improving us it's the cows and
humans oh is that one and it's
specifically white Farmers it's always
white Farmers I don't know why they
don't choose anybody else that's why I
say pick a Colts fan to go to the Moon
they get you so much they they probably
give them a break
so much they've been getting anal probed
and [__] picked up from their farms
for so long just let one see the [__]
space guys or have been taking it to
them
just for once the guys you've been
[__] off choose a person of color the
guy's been [__] on for so many
generations so Steve how did you how did
you get so into the moon well it all
started when I was uh a kid true story I
went to a planetarium when I was a kid
and like I just was blown the [__] away
about space about space about you know
all the plants especially Uranus
obviously because it's hilarious isn't
that the sickest way to learn though
yeah for sure that [__] is tight it is
but I was like I was getting on Facebook
checking them off from the library and
you know how like when you open them up
they had that plastic around them
because yeah at the library yeah you
open it like crinkles up and [__] yeah
then I got to look at space photos I'm
like whoa because this is like 90s and
like these were the first pictures of
space like taken like 20 years ago yeah
it was fun seeing Jupiter and Saturn and
almost [__] and like I just knew that we
live in an era where people who lived
100 years ago never even saw like what
it's like to be in a plane and like we
take that for granted so like the fact
that I could look at pictures on planets
all planets and then now in my you know
I'm an adult I can look on the surface
of planets and see like what the [__] is
going on is wild I love plants I I also
fell in love with [__] space and [__]
like that because of my physical
sciences book as a kid and you see all
the crust in the core and you like that
was always really cool you know what's
kind of random and funny
um so you know how like there's like uh
like for example K-pop groups it seems
random but
um a lot of them those Idol groups they
get formed on reality TV shows so like
people compete and then like the winners
of those shows become a group that is
like managed by a record level yeah so
uh there's like TV show in Taiwan that
like was doing the same thing and uh the
the teams or or the the groups that were
in competition with each other are named
after planets right like Sailor Moon
guess who won who won Uranus and Uranus
it's literally now an official Taiwanese
K-pop group or or teapot group I'm
already a fan you're right I think I
guess [__] yeah I'm just saying I think
that's
interesting is that your favorite band
Uranus
I'm Uranus I'm your fire your desire
imagine if that was the song
the song Uranus
um
no she's down for anal
from Uranus hi Joe's Mom bye Joe's mom